tu as vu vincent diaby en césar on
sature repartira pas les mains vides si
j'avais tout ça
je plaisante je sais que ta compagne et
si bien accompagné d'ailleurs et je je
m'excuse valeur pour la différence d'âge
en plus je veux dire en année cinéma ça
va vous n'êtes pas si éloignées non
parce qu'une année cinéma ça vaut dix
ans vous avez qu à trois ans des cartes
pas non c'est juste que voilà je voulais
juste dire mince tant que bons avec moi
tu ferais peut-être pas du surf tous les
jours mais on pourrait parler des choses
de notre âge pour échanger sur nos
coloscopie dit non mais ça a du bon
défend pour elle par des rhumatismes la
prostate mon arthrose et puis parler de
tout ce qui n'existe plus quand tu vois
des vinyles des dvd de pia zadora la
liberté d'expression nous a pas enfin
bon je te fout la pêche c'est marrant
d'ailleurs je vous regarde c'est bizarre
comme vous avez tous choisi de vous
marier avec des jolies filles
d'originalité coincer ces mamans ce truc
c'est une mode je sais que vous pourriez
vous démarquer quoi je serais vous
j'irais voilà la différence le parti de
la normalité quoi au moins où vous vous
démarquez tout de suite quoi voilà une
fan de la vraie vie c'est bien aussi
c'est vrai c'est beau la vraie vie c'est
tellement beau d'ailleurs qu'on qu'on en
fait des films documentaires
quelle transition pour remettre le césar
les fonds n'a pas le temps pour un jeu
césar du meilleur film documentaire
j'accueille les tells éternellement
jeune pardon antoine de caunes